on a donc en France 45 ans de de
problèmes urbains de rapport avec la
police de euh de
problèmes liés à
une jeunesse urbaine ou périphérique et
euh au fil du temps
c'est cette jeunesse là
euh n'est pas évidemment repérable par
la statistique officielle mais commence
à faire corp
à former un groupe social pour reprendre
le terme de Sébastien je m'explique
j'avais fait moi aussi une enquête sur
les contrôles d'identité à Paris on
avait fait suivre des policiers sans
qu'ils s'en rendent compte
pour collecter les variables qui
caractérisent les personnes qui le
contrôlent à Paris hein g garde du Nord
Châtelet dans 5 endroits différents et
puis on avait comparé avec la population
qui est présente sur ces lieux-là et et
on s'était rendu compte que dans les
lieux
où les personnes blanches sont
minoritaires
elles sont sous-crôlé sous-crôlé par
rapport à leur part dans la population
disponible dans les lieux où les
personnes blanches sont très
majoritaires elles sont également sous
contrôlé autrement dit euh la
probabilité d'être contrôlé ne dépend
pas du tout de la nature de la
composition de la population disponible
et de la couleur de peau des individus
il faut ajouter à ça que la couleur de
peau n'est pas le seul critère qui
déclenche qui est associé au
contrôle l'âge le sexe et l'accoutrement
vestimentaire quand vous cumulez quatre
variables qui sont jeunes hommes non
blanc habillé de manière typiquement
jeune et en particulier on avait
identifié jogging casquette B
casquette ou capuche bref Couvrechef
typiquement jeune pour le dire
ainsi là vous avez un risque d'être
contrôlé qui est démesuré par rapport à
celui des populations
autres au au bout de 40 ans lorsque vous
avez un acte de des de la puissance
publique des pouvoirs des forces de
l'ordre qui s'adressent systématiquement
aux mêmes populations que ces
populations par les émeutes mais aussi
par leur r par tout un ensemble de
choses décrivent ces phénomènes
décrivent également ce qu'elles
perçoivent comme étant une non réponse à
ces phénomènes vous créez là un ce qu'on
appelle un sentiment d'appartenance une
population qui va être invisible dans la
statistique publique mais qui va avoir
une réalité substantielle et cette
population c'est-à-dire une population
de jeunes urbains surexposés à la
tension policière c'est celle-ci qui est
évidemment au cœur des émeutes